today is the big day 100 years ago today
on November 25th 1915 Albert Einstein
lectures at the Prussian Academy for the
4th time in four weeks and this time
he's able to stand proudly in front of
the assembled crowd and announced to
them and to the world that he had
finally completed the equations of the
general theory of relativity in
equations that he announced that day
they're quite beautiful here they are
these are known as the Einstein field
equations the left side hero describes
geometry warps and curves in space and
time this is known as the metric tensor
the scalar curvature the Ricci tensor
the right-hand side this describes the
stuff in a region of space moving
through a region this is known as the
stress energy tensor and it describes
all of the matter and energy within the
environment and the equality between the
two embodies the heart of einstein's
idea that matter and energy warps the
fabric of space and time and when you
supplement that with a little equation
over here
that describes what are known as
geodesics roughly speaking the shortest
possible trajectory through a warp
region of space and time these equations
together allow you to determine how an
object will move through a curved
environment in essence Einsteins version
of how an object moves under the force
of gravity and the picture that you get
is really quite wonderful
Einstein is telling us that the earth
the moon the Sun they all warped the
space-time environment we're only
showing the warping of space right here
than any other object that's moving
through this environment it gets nudged
around by the warps and curves in
essence that is how gravity is
communicated from one place to another
warps and curves that then influence the
motion of another body that's moving by
now this was a triangle right this is
what Einstein was working toward for
almost a decade and finally on November
25th 1915 he could announce to the world
that he has this new understanding of
the force of gravity what about
Einsteins competitor David Hilbert well
David Hilbert came up with his own
version of the equations usually
expressed in this mathematical form but
in the published paper in which Hilbert
gave this equation to the world Hilbert
made it abundantly clear that he
believed that Albert Einstein deserved
credit for the discovery of the general
theory of relativity a wonderfully
magnanimous conclusion to this
competitive spirit that drove these two
monumental minds toward the final form
of the general theory of relativity but
even so Hilbert does get some credit
this equation is known in the scientific
literature as the Einstein Hilbert
action so this equation right here this
captures Hilbert's contribution to the
discovery of the general theory of
relativity but regardless of which
equation you use the final picture well
it's just beautiful it's just wonderful
Einstein's Hilbert they're telling us
that gravity is communicated by the
shape
of the universe warps and curves in
space and time this is the heart of the
new picture of how gravity works this is
the heart the general theory